welcome everyone this is our second
seminar
from the refugee
program
for the fall 2021
today we have the pleasure of having dr
danny bachat
he is an associate professor at brown
university watson institute for
international and public affairs
and a non-resident senior fellow at the
brookings institution global economy and
development program
he is an israeli and venezuelan
economist with affiliation to the growth
lab at harvard center for international
development
cs group munich and iza institute of
labor economics
dr bahar research sits at the
intersection of international economics
and economic development in particular
he focuses on the diffusion of
technology and knowledge within and
across borders as well as topics related
to structural transformation and
productivity dynamics
lately his focus has been towards
migrants and refugees as an asset in the
process of economic development
today he will be speaking about the
global mobile inventor so
danny the floor is yours
thank you there and thanks everybody for
for coming or joining on zoom it's it's
great to be here i just moved to new
england and one of the parents they told
me you're close to yale and all those
universities and now when i get the
chance to go to yale i'm going on zoom
but you know next time
and thank you for the invitation it's
great to be here with you guys
so i i know that this is a series about
refugees and i am doing some work on
refugees but this one in particular um
i'm barely i'm not going to talk about
refugees so so it's going to be a little
bit hopefully it stands out
um
and but of course in the q a you know we
can talk more about other stuff we're
doing on the on the refugee aspect but
but this is kind of a bit of a different
crowd
um and it's i think a very exciting
project that we we we started we just
started and when i made we just started
it's just two years ago before covered
um and it is joined with rashford from
harvey school and ernest migueles from
the university of bordeaux who i think
is in the crowd so
um if there are questions on the chat i
think mms will be
um he probably has answers that i don't
so he will be able to jump in
anyway
let me start a little bit with some
i guess some motivation um
and
this quote we found um from a from i
think a philosopher carlos sipola who
who said through the ages the main
channel for the diffusion of innovation
has been the migration of people
um and of course here
one of the
one of the most notable examples
is um
this generation of migrant scientists
who arrived to the u.s
and you could very much say you know in
a refugee status the refugees that
didn't exist really
before world war ii
um
and uh you know it's it's attributed
that these these scientists um in their
many different fields
um really shaped or reshaped on all
science spectrum in in the us and in the
world
um and you know one and there have been
research done on this i'm going to
mention it but of course the research by
petra mosser
um stands out and you know it it's
pretty clear that
uh despite the horrible circumstances
through which these scientists had to
come had to flee their countries
um
the the the the the success of the us in
in this case in everything that has to
do with science and innovation
in a big part is due to
to to this transfer of brains and of
people who will settle here and i think
this paper goes a little bit to speak
about this
let me start with one example of what is
it that we're after
um
an anecdotal example
meet ismail mena
ismail mena um he is uh what i think is
a pioneer inventor
he patented the first ever
patent in chile
in the technology class a61b
which is a cpc classification
um in in in in the uspto the us patents
and trade office so so the first ever
patent that happened out of chile in
that classification
was made by this a gentleman called
mena
and this
that the subclass a61b
of course we don't know exactly what it
means but it's everything that has to do
with instruments
in terms of diagnostics and surgical and
and
medical instruments basically
um after israel patented ismail mena
sorry patented this first patent in
chile ever in 1996 there were 17 more
patents in that class
by inventors in chile
um and by uh
these are 70 patents by 19 other
inventors in chile that happened after
this first patent
so
you know
one question i i i had is like how come
how did this guy do it no how do you get
to a country
um or like you are you're an inventor
and you start patenting something that
nobody else in the country has done
before
you know it takes some i don't know
courage creativity
so i went and looked i mean this is a
cherry picked example of course but i
went and i looked into this plastic so
this is the pattern that is my elmena
uh filed in 1996
um it was filed in 1996 it was
surrounded in 1998
we can talk about we're going to talk
about that later but you see it's a
patent with a lot of people
some of them in the u.s
um but is my mena is in chile it's in
so of course you could say well you know
he was patenting with other people that
knew about this and all that and that's
all fair
but but stick with me for a minute for
the motivation for the story but what's
interesting here is that when i go and i
search more of these of this person
i found another patent in 1994 two years
before in the same subclass
so exactly the same technologies
um where is my men i was partaking in
los angeles
right so so he it turns out he was in
the us
where maybe he did his degree where he
was working he patented he learned about
this technology and then he moved to
chile which presumably is his home
country and then he patented more in
that same technology
so
our answer and this is what i'm going to
try to show you some evidence in this
talk or answer is how did he do it how
did ishmael
was the first person to ever patent a
new technology for chile
is because he was a global mobile
inventor
danny can i ask a question for
clarification here so the story
i mean one way to interpret your story
is that he is an inventor wherever he
goes
he invents and he takes inventions to a
new place right another way to interpret
the story is that you move to a new
institutional environment
where you might
you might not have necessarily a new
idea
but in that environment with those
regulations you might want to patent
the same invention or the same idea that
you had
that there's some value to patenting in
the u.s there's some separate values
happening in chile as well
um
and which which interpretation is uh is
the one you would like us to
i
if i understood it right i think it's
more of the first one
are you by the second where are you are
you second one is like there's not
necessarily a new
innovation that's moving to a new place
the same innovation given a new
regulatory environment i might want to
patent again i see no i think it's more
of the first one because these are all
patents in the usp
in the same office
so so it's not that he's just
replicating something in another country
but
from chile he's now doing an additional
patent
in the same patent office so it's
something above and beyond
i see so when we move to the
quantitative aspect of your work it'll
be holding constant the institutional
environment
like in terms of like the federal bank
okay absolutely yes yes exactly yes
that's a good that's a great point
okay so i mean i'm making here a big
claim
and i'm gonna try to show evidence um
and to see how far we can get
um so so what do we do in this paper in
particular so um
we will explore this idea of what we
call global mobile inventors or gmis um
and we're gonna try to answer questions
such as
um how common are these gmis
how common are these gmis and and how do
they defer from other type of inventors
are they really do they really have very
different characteristics
can gmi explain in various new
technology classes in the countries they
go to and and this is as much said yes
keeping constant as much as we can
including the institutional um
environment
what else can we learn about gmis being
pioneers and in the process of diffusion
of knowledge and technology
and and here i must be i'm gonna be
honest and upfront um and and and please
keep bringing these questions you know
we delete work in progress
we don't have yet
a fancy identification strategy
i'm not sure we really need it because
we because in essence i think a lot of
what we're trying to do is really
descriptive to try to show the evidence
of what who are these people and i think
we have some pretty strong and robust
patterns that makes it interesting
um
however you know i'm going to talk about
that we we we are still trying to see if
there's uh uh there's room for
improvement when it comes to
identification and you know of course we
welcome ideas on that front
i have a question
yes
so uh
does it matter if the movement of the
gmis are volitional or non-volition
are
well traditional like you know if they
intend to move or they were forced to
move
um
i mean it matters in terms of of
endogenous selection right yeah but
you're going to yeah um of course
it doesn't matter
um
and i think that's that's going to be
your biggest challenge but but here you
know without getting too much
ahead of time
there are kind of two views of the world
here i mean one one of them
let's imagine a firm
wants
you know that they don't have the local
the local
knowhow or the local skills too
and they will actually bring somebody
from the same firm from another location
from another firm
that is a self-selection process you
know happening in process the question
whether
you know that still means that the
counterfactual firm wouldn't be able to
continue pattern with other person
[Music]
so you know we don't want to make a
strong claim about that but but i am
putting up front here the fact that you
know we're not
coming here with saying like this is a
perfect identification there could be
important election issues
we try to show you know
we try to go as clean as we can
but but your point is great and
and yes i mean most of these moves are
gonna be voluntarily
thank you
um i i hope though that you still find
cool and interesting what we're gonna
find even though um we do have room for
improvement in terms of identification
strategy
so so at the macro level it's like you
know the evidence is quite clear that
like a
movement of european jews to let's say
america
led to a lot of innovations you know
right
but at the individual level i have not
seen um
the evidence so it's
very curious
yeah so i think this is an attempt of
doing that um you know i think that that
that the work by petra moser and and the
work i um
i have special mention to them by um
chai things comforting coffers um show a
little bit of that on on that direction
but um
not so much on on the emergence of new
technologies
they measure the the knowledge if you
should through others
and i think we're we're going to
that direction as you said
all right so so some of the main
findings um
put out there so so first of all we do
find that these gmis are superstars um
and i'm gonna
specify this very clearly they have
longer careers they patent much more
and higher quality innovations
but there's of course something special
about them
um
what i think is our main and most
important result
is this one and is that gmis are
significantly more present
in the first stages of the development
of a new technology class in their
countries of destinations
and and i'm going to show you a lot of
evidence about this and it goes back a
little bit to the example of the
beginning of
el mena
we also find that this prevalence
disappears over time so like as as the
life cycle of the technology advances
we see less presence of gmis
which was could be interpreted as a sign
that once
once
the knowledge has been transferred
as more and more patterns are being
invented in that technology the
knowledge becomes embedded in the local
inventors and and once i get to that
graph i'm going to be more specific
about what i'm saying
we don't find strong evidence though
that the quality of the patenting um
significantly changes when they're when
there are gmis involved in the first few
patients of technology in a given
country
um so we find that the technologies
start off with a higher presence of gmis
but when it comes to quality
you know as much as we can measure the
counter factual we don't see it
all
right so it's very hard to do justice to
a very long literature but but but a
little bit of what we think is our main
constitution
um
first of all on the huge
literature on the globalization of
innovation um
you know there's a lot of papers showing
that innovation is becoming more
globally integrated
there's many more
patents there are global collaborations
there's a lot of across site across
side systems
um
and also
there's a lot of
recent evidence but but very growing and
very fascinating
that a lot of the immigration innovation
is happening
thanks to immigration flows
um and you know we have here a long list
and i i think here that our particular
contribution is that we come and provide
evidence of a new aspect of
globalization
and go very deep into this phenomenon
called the gmis which is like really
starting the people these innovators
that are moving across borders
and how are they shaping the innovation
in the countries they they arrive to
much beyond citations
a lot of the focus on this in this
literature has been on citations
how knowledge transfers through
citations we're actually looking more at
the emergence of new technologies
um and of course in that sense there's a
long literature on on human mobility and
the diffusion of knowledge and and you
know sanjiv also
mentioned that there's a there's good it
has been very well established it's more
than macro level that there will be time
things
um you know micro diffuse know-how and
technologies and there's a long list and
as i said before i think there's a
special mention to to the world by petra
monster and authors and shy versus
who really look at the evidence more
micro of scientists importing knowledge
um shy does shy bernstein golfers do it
more on with citations
and co-authors do it more with science
because of inventors and patterns
um
you know
in a few words i think we we are really
bringing some you know the universe of
patents using micro data to measure the
emergence of new technologies through
the fusion
and this builds a little bit on a
previous work of of ours with with
hurry and uh
we do this a little bit at a macro level
okay so or or the the the data we're
going to use is or our main um
data source is patents view patent view
is a website or a data visualization
tool
that is maintained by the office of the
chief economies of the uspto and
partners that includes
several organizations and universities
the university of amherst
is involved here
and
the i'm going to tell you what makes
this very special um if you have if you
don't know about it the platform
contains the universe of patents granted
by the uspto from 1976
to present
um
that doesn't mean
i mean
we
these are granted from 1976 so you might
see patents that have been applied to
before 1976
um so in in essence what makes this um
data set special is that they they use
some complex algorithms on machine
learning to design the same big way the
names of the inventors and of assignees
which are the firms that the patents are
assigned to um
where they m most of the time when the
invert if an inventor is working with if
i ibm
the inventor is listed on the patent but
the assignee is going to be ibm for
instance
um so so we have a unique identifier for
both um so so basically we can really
track
inventors across time and space so each
time an inventor will patent an
invention
that inventor will list
his or her address
um at the time of filing
um
and and of course the assignees so we
can really
see all the movement of people as long
as they're patenting which is important
right so as long as we see patenting
activity we can really see mobility of
people across borders or
i mean we can do it across cities if we
wanted to in this paper we're focusing
just across borders
um and of course we can identify
assignees which is on firms which is
important because
we we don't do a whole lot of that right
now but we are also looking a little bit
about and maybe sanji this goes a little
bit to your question not exactly but we
are looking a little bit into
movements within the firm or across
firms
and you know we see some heterogeneity
there um and but of course we have much
more information to work here if you
wanted to
so our example um
you know we actually gonna limit our
patents to that have an application date
between 1970 and 2015. so so as i said
before the patents are granted
starting in 76 but i could have filed a
patent in 1970
that was granted in 76 or vice versa
there's a patent that was granted in 76
but it could have been
applied you know i could have filed it
10 years ago 10 years before or five
years before
so we have all these we stopped in 2015
just because some often we use like
citations measures and
to to to avoid like results being biased
by right tail censoring
uh we just try to cut it a little bit
because you will see like towards the
end of the sample you see a lot of right
still censoring of many measures but
none of this is really changing our
results
um
so we
when it comes to when
an invention is happening we're going to
use the application date or priority
date if earlier
um so again the application date is when
i go to the patent office and say i want
to apply with these patents like when we
you know the submission date of the
journal right which is different than
the publication day
um
there there are certain patterns
um
when
again we're using here only the uspto so
the us patents and trademark office
we're using only one office
and of course there are inventors
everywhere in the world that can patent
in through the u.s office
sometimes these inventors also patent in
the european patent office so they're
also patented in the japanese patent
office and when this happens
if you patented let's say you patented
first in the european patent office and
then you patent the same the same
invention in the uspto so to have more
jurisdictions
we actually gonna use the the date of
the first patent that you filed in this
case the the european patent office
right so if the pri if we have a
priority a day that is earlier we're
gonna use that
and this is pretty standard in the
literature we just do it because that's
the time where that most closely
resembles when the innovation actually
happens as opposed to the to the
granting date
um this is just like admin right i'm
going with
three with you
um so our sample includes about 6
million granted patents and they belong
to about 15 million inventors
um
and each patent is classified to
to a technology subclass according to
the cpc codes which is the one that
uspto uses which is the cooperative
patent classification these are like
four digits or four character
patent classes and there are about 623
of them
um so every time i'm talking about
technology class or technology subclass
sometimes i mix it too but i'm referring
to these i'm referring to the four digit
cpc codes
and you know we're gonna we we are gonna
complement um
oops yeah we just i'm going to talk
about this later we complement this with
some quality level measures from from
oecd oecd data set by by sports scorch
yarini dernis and with crisco
okay let me start showing you some some
some data
um interrupt me if if there are any
questions so so this is for instance
just simply like
how many patterns are filed per year in
our sample from 1970 to 2015 of course
at the beginning they're very very few
because
again because patents view starts only
with patents granted in 1976 there's
very few patents that were filed in 1970
and didn't and and waited six years to
be granted so of course at the beginning
there's very little
but overall this reflects i mean i think
what we should take from this bracket it
reflects that you know during the 90s as
expected there was a huge boom in
innovation in in patents filed all over
the world so so
um this is kind of what we're working
with
um
okay
this is a very cool graph that is not
exactly about our sample but it's but i
thought it was cool to show and it's
basically where are the inventors and
this takes the uspto it takes inventors
from other offices
um and basically
you know we geo located with geocoded
data you see where actually the
inventors we
located um and
i mean no surprise most of them of
course in the us europe and and asia and
east asia
um
and and you know very little across the
developing countries um as we know most
innovation most formal innovation
happens in in these countries
um
oh this is not showing there's some
there's
um anyway
um okay so
the i'm sorry that the legend here is
not complete so so basically this is
another graph
showing a little bit what which one are
the
you know where
in which countries are the inventors
that are filing the most in terms of
countries as a whole and this is
basically
showing you um
you know
the us is this
purple
line it doesn't show in the legend but
the u.s of course is is the number one
fighter of patents or inventors in the
us are the number one
inventors
fighters of patents then you have japan
if i'm not mistaken
um then you have germany
china is this green line that you see
how it's rising um very rapidly in the
past um two decades
anyway just some descriptive statistics
for you to see but um but just just to
show you kind of a little bit the extent
to which we have data
can you please ask us a simple question
yes please well can you trace these uh
inventors to organization that they were
part of
yes
okay like
do you have any sense like you know
maybe in japan like you know it's a more
self-employed inventors
who are active or in america it's more
organization based do you have any sense
about
i don't have things right now but i but
that's very easy to find out i mean i
can follow up a fine um
my sense is that most of them i i think
that they're very ernest is in the crowd
he can write in the chat but he knows
this data pretty well but uh i think
that most of these patents are you all
you mostly always have an organization
behind you it could be a university
but i know that multinationals account
for like i don't know 80 but a big you
know a big chunk of the patents that are
filed so i think most of them actually
do belong to an organization
okay
but i can that's easy that's really easy
to look in this data okay thanks
um
all right
so so let's go to the mid here um
so who is a global mobile inventor how
do we define a human hair and and and we
here have to make a little bit of some
arbitrary
um decisions so so basically you know
the short answer is like anybody any
inventor who patents in more than one
country throughout his or her career
and hasn't moved across borders um we
classify that person as a gmi
uh this doesn't mean
this person is a migrant we are aware
that we can with these data classify
somebody as a migrant or not because we
don't know the country that they were
born in
there were some
database databases on the european
patent office that had your nationality
we don't have that here
um so we're not
making a big claim about migration but
you know
it's fair to think that a lot of these
people are actually migrants
i have a question
hi denny hi there this is aj i have a
quick question so by the way that you're
defining your gmi this to me sounds like
by definition you're excluding people
who would for instance come to the us
study in the u.s get their phd whatever
and not have time to
let's say apply for a patent and then
start working in a place like google
and then actually be incentivized to
uh to to apply for a patent there so
you're essentially missing out on a
group of younger generation
uh
who get into that stage of applying for
patterns a little bit differently
so could you speak to it a little bit
more and what do you think
this type of exclusion does to your um
your results
yeah i know that's a good point and we
are i mean i think your story is
somebody
like i'm an immigrant in the u.s and and
let's say my first parent is in the us
and you know i don't move anywhere else
i wouldn't be a gmi in this data set
um
we do have and i'm gonna get to that
some
name
analysis where we kind of try to based
on your location and your name
um try to say something whether you are
an immigrant or an attorney
um and we do some work with that but i
don't have a great answer for i mean
it's a great point i take it and you're
right you're absolutely right we're not
i mean for you to be i mean let me even
go one more step there
for you to be a gmi you need to have at
least two patents
right you can't precisely both in your
home country or wherever you start from
another place
and if you follow this logic that you
just opened up as well if you're coming
from a country that has heavy
regulations on patents applying for a
patent then by definition you're
excluding
very low income settings
absolutely no i agree i mean that i i
guess that you know the boring answer to
your very good question is like that's
why we're not we're we're not using the
same migrant
uh it goes very far we're using mobile
inventors as people who actually do our
invent we know they're inventors and
move around
it's hard for me to say how that will
kind of buy us what we're doing um
and i mean if anything i guess it could
underestimate what we're doing
i think you may be overestimating how
creme de la creme these people are
because you're essentially
removing the people
who are earlier on in their careers so
you're really comparing people who've
had a chance to
both apply for a patent in the in their
domestic or wherever and then somewhere
else so you're really really looking at
people who are
top achievers yeah so so when i'm gonna
i'm gonna show you the first comparison
in a couple of slides and we do
i mean this is not perfect but it kind
of goes
between your opponents like we compare
them to other inventors that also have
two patterns
um just to make a little more apples
than apples but but you're you're right
i'm not evading your point
this is a limitation
you know
and and we have to keep i mean we're
open about it and we're we're not going
to claim otherwise you're absolutely
right
thank you for responding so uh kindly
yeah of course
okay so um
you know then then so so let's bear with
me that you know we we're going with
this definition based on on the data
and then a question arise which is like
okay you're a gmi but for how long are
you at gmi are you hmi for
you know the first
hour since you moved and i mean it's
over the first patent are you a gmi
forever are you hdmi for six months for
two years
we have to define some
framework
to do it and here i'm actually going to
show you how we do that within with a
cartoon
um
there you go
doesn't look great but uh anyway so so
so let's say
we see
this inventor um she has a patent in
country a right
and we're gonna have three and we're
gonna be using three definitions of gmis
um
in in year one this person patented so
we see her in our data
then we see her again on year three on
country b so she you know we assumed and
i think it's a fair assumption she
should have moved in between year one
and year three
and you know just just to keep it simple
we're just doing this example where this
person actually stays in country we can
have people moving around and and i can
answer questions about that but
let's keep it simple for now
so we have three definitions the first
one let's say is the gmi just for the
first pattern so so we count you only
as a gmi when you do your first patent
in another country and if you if i see
you patenting again in the future
you're not a gma anymore
that's definition number one
then we have what i think is kind of the
moderate one which is gmi for one year
which is like we can't use the gmi after
you move and
every time you patent within the first
year
um you are you're still a gmi right
you're still like you know just game
might be in the process of bringing the
know-how etc etc
and then we have kind of the most extra
i don't know if extreme but the most
the largest definition is like well you
have a gmi always which is you know it
doesn't matter what happened as long as
you move once you're always a gmi
we have to set some structure and this
is the way we we went through it for for
for most of the results i'm going to
tell you today
um we are i'm going to show you results
with the one year gmi definition
you know
everything is really robust with with
all of them but you know we just have to
stick to one for i don't want to show
you three tables every time for
everything but
we're using this definition and
just to set the stage
okay
so let me show you a little bit more
data so so
um
tell me if that wasn't clear this is
important right
i guess if there any questions just jump
in
okay so so this is just a snapshot
basically of them of the top 50
corridors between
you know 2015 and 2019 so basically what
this graph is doing is showing
all the movements that have been
between 2015 and 2019 in the top 50
countries that have movements
um this actually should be
these are not 50 countries these are i
think 20. so that that's a typo there
i'm sorry so i mean basically what this
graph is telling you this is the us this
blue
you know
this blue part here is the us and and
and
these blue lines are all the inventors
leaving the us moving out of the us
you see a lot of them are going to china
a lot of them are going to canada
a lot of them are going to japan
et cetera et cetera it sounds like great
you know you could you could think and
we do find evidence of that that these
are kind of retro knees or returning
um china is a big ho it's a big country
of origin of many gmis a lot of them
going to the us
uh but also to taiwan interestingly
um
and and all over okay so this is kind of
a glimpse of of the richness of the data
we have
um
i have a lot of descriptive graphs so
i'm gonna for the sake of time i need to
to skip some but this is also like how
many movements are year to year in our
data set um so you see in you know in in
the latest years first of all you see
that this is a growing phenomenon i mean
in the 1990s as compared to today i mean
these the numbers of international
movements of inventors have quadrupled
um so so it's a really rising phenomenon
which we think is really important
um and you know
a smaller share of all these movements
are people
moving within the firm but actually most
of them are moving across firms
um this is something we can do um
sanjeev with your with what you were
referring to before the the fact that we
can really track assignments to
uh our firms with a unique identifier
uh this is interesting i wasn't really
expecting that most of the movement will
be across
uh firms
um
this is too much information here uh but
just uh i'll walk you very quickly i
mean these are the main corridors
um of movements uh you know for five
year periods
so so you you know you you start seeing
that the first corridor
in the 80s and the 90s was from great
britain to the usa and then it changed
from usa to china which is really
interesting
and and you start seeing really a lot of
changes in the past 20 years of how
things are moving
um and um
so so now let me
go to
uh
th this does not make justice to edge's
previous comment but i think it's kind
of a step in that direction
so so again we we're not able to
explicitly find a gmail as an immigrant
but we do perform a name analysis for
those purposes and i think you probably
have seen many papers doing this we're
not doing anything very new so i'm kind
of going to go a little bit fast over
this unless there's questions
but basically you know we we we
with several algorithms
um
basically we rely on the ibm global name
recognition system
which is based and ernest is here ernest
who's my co-author he's here and he did
this so he might correct me
um this is based emotional names of
people who are coming immigrating to the
us um
so this is mostly for outside of us
names
um
so using this data set we can actually
track
and and give a probability essentially
of the country you are from both from
your first name and your last name
um
so you know we take the names from
patton's view this name for instance la
roya rajiv
um we know that the surname
you know has
99 percent likelihood of being from
india one percent like would have been
from france
and the
first name
81 likelihood of being from india
and and these are the other countries so
based on this
we actually
define
uh based on your last name what is your
um
the country of your ethnicity if you may
um using this we kind of we we mark we
do our best this is not a great this is
not a perfect algorithm but we do our
best to mark you
if you're a gmi as an immigrant or as a
returnee
so what does that mean
wei rao for instance who's in our data
set and he has for instance three
patents as you see here on the left
is the same inventor has the same
inventor iv
and he patents the first two patents in
china and then moves to the us
so he is a gmi and he we mark him as an
immigrant in the us
um and not our attorney right because
his last name and his name is resembles
names in china
um this is kind of the easy case also we
have if if the gmi
is coming in the host country we mark
that person as a returnee right so
marco paniello
a patented in in great britain and then
we see uh marco uh patented from italy
um and this name resembles an italian
last name a name so so we count that
person as a returnee
then we get into more complicated things
that i'm gonna skip um
because then what do you do if
if if um you know for anyway i'm gonna
skip this part because it gets a little
bit complicated but i'm happy to talk
about it offline that there's some
there's a bunch of cases and we try to
make justice but in in
you know in the big scheme of things the
point here is we we do our best to try
to define if a person is a immigrant or
attorney based based on names
when we do that
and here i'm showing you again these
corridors
um
you know things kind of change a little
bit so so you see that when it comes to
immigrants we see that um
you know traditionally that the most
common corridor was from japan to the us
then in the mid-2000s it comes from
china to the us
um
you know also
you start seeing like most a lot of you
you start seeing the us as a recipient
country much more often
and when you look at returnees you kind
of the the picture turns around so you
start seeing the u.s as the sending
country much more often in the receiving
countries you see china korea
um
and uh you know
germany india you start seeing india in
this top 10 so so you start seeing also
some developing countries
um all right so so
this to me i think it's a very important
graph and and here if i haven't
convinced you already how important this
phenomena is i think that this graph at
least to me it's convincing
um
there and
here basically we're comparing how
frequent
how many patents or what's a share of
patents that have gmis
across time and here we're measuring
gmi's with the three different
definitions of course when we when we
use the most generous definition of
always you know the share of patents is
very very high because it accumulates
people
um
but and here we're but we're basically
comparing the share of patents of people
who are jmi's to the share of patents
that are gcps which are global
collaborative patents
um there's a very important important
influential paper by bill care and and
saricare
uh showing this important phenomenon of
these global collaborative patterns
patents that are filed by inventors
living in two different countries or two
or more different countries
you know they claim it's it's a big
phenomenon it's a great paper um you
know you can learn a lot there about
about this
globalization of innovation and here i
think we're showing that when we look at
gdmis
it's a very comparable phenomenon when
it comes to its size and velocity
so so
so um
i think that this was an important graph
for us to to you know allow it to
compare apples with apples
okay um this is going i'm slower than
what i thought so so i want to i don't
want to try to get to the results but um
this um here is kind of what i'm trying
to to to show you know who are these
people really and how do they be fair so
so for a bunch of different measures
here um i'm not gonna go through all of
them but like how many patents you filed
throughout your life and how many
countries you filed throughout your life
how many firms did you work with or like
how many assignees are your patents
what share of your patents are patented
for the top 100 assignees for the firms
that patent the most how many active
years you have since your first patent
until your most recent paths and then a
bunch of things including some quality
measures and so on
this is
the mean for gmi's for a g for this is
the this number for the average gmi so
the average gmi pattern 17 patterns
throughout his or her lifetime
it patents in two
plus countries throughout his or her
lifetime it patents for almost four
four different firms
half of their patents or almost half of
their patents are in the top hundred as
chinese
um they're active for almost 15 years
right and and then you have a bunch a
bunch of
other measures and and you know their
quality
um
it's also quite high as compared to the
two followings that i'm going to tell
you so so the first two columns here is
like comparing to the average non-gmi so
everybody who's an inventor who doesn't
move
of course here you know the country
if you're already on gmi by definition
you only have one country right
and here to admit make a little bit of
javascript towards what asia was saying
before which is a great point we are
comparing it also to
people who patent
two patents or more because maybe the
superstars doesn't come from the fact
that you're moving the superstars come
from the fact that you patented more
than once
and even there yet we do see important
differences so so so so these deltas
here are the differences
between
these gmis and these non-gmis and you
know across the board these gmis are
really superstars patenting higher
quality patterned them for a longer time
making more patents you know
working for bigger firms et cetera et
cetera
um
so so
all right so
let me um go a little bit more into
the more a little bit more rigorous
empirical work that we're that we're
doing um
so
one of the main questions that is
wrapping us is like you know what is
what role gmi's play in in the in the
life cycle of a country and technology
so what we do for this is that we
basically sort
for each country and each technology
class so think about you know each
country and each four digit technology
we sort chronologically all the patterns
within that cell
right from the first ever patent
ever in in for that country in that cell
for instance in chile
in medical instruments the first one
would be the patent by ismail meno we
saw at the beginning
and then we store them chronologically
until the most recent pattern we have in
the data
and then we just simply divided in 10
chunks like 10 decimals the first 10
percent the second 10 percent the third
ten percent and so on
so we estimate
um
we
we want to try to get a sense of how
frequent or how likely it is to see a
gmi in each one of these deciles
the first decile ever the second vessel
and so on but we wanna i mean we have
enough power to add some control so just
we don't wanna do just a simple average
so so basically what we do is that on
the left
we run a regression on the left we have
like a binary parallel with whether
whether you are a gmi or not
here we have a set of dummies um
pair country and technology um for the
10 deciles
okay
and then we add some countries fixed
effects some technology or year fixed
effects
um
and you know we do a lot more robust
steps but but this is what we find i
think this graph to us is kind of the
it's um i i i don't know about you but i
really like it um so this is what this
graph is showing us
this graph is showing the prep the
probability of seeing a gmi
uh for a given for the average country
and technology in each one of the
deciles
of the life cycle of that technology in
that country
so what you're seeing everything is
relative to the most recent 10 to the
most recent decile so the latest 10 of
patents
of course here we have you know we we
only keep countries and technologies
that have at least 10 patents
um
um
so so what we find here is that
in the first 10
of patents ever in a given country or
the technology
you have a
uh
like
a little bit more than half a percentage
point higher in the likelihood of seeing
a gmi than in the most recent
decile
you you still see that in the second
vessel you still see it in the third
decile
it starts this the the the significance
of the estimate starts disappearing
after the the fourth the fourth thesale
so after 40 percent or after like you
know a few
a few patents in the country
it seems that gmi's are not
present anymore in the life cycle of
these patterns which
could be interpreted and that's our
interpretation
that as time goes by the ability to keep
innovating in that same technology is
fully embedded in local inventors
not in not in global
not in gmis
danny
here could it be just the same inventors
that say uh file the first button
but because of your definition of gmi
they just stopped being considered gmis
or is that real that so we we try this
with all these three definitions and and
it's robust so so you know the more
if you use the the the
if you use the always definition which
is the more the most exhaustive actually
it's gonna it's it's gonna look even
stronger right so i mean i think that
the significance will disappear maybe
later on
uh but if you use only the first pattern
you will still see a presence
definitely in the first decile um and
weaker afterwards but you still see the
pattern very strongly
um okay i'm just going to skip this this
is just what i said and this is robust
to using
different gmi definitions using even
stricter fixed effects different levels
of aggregation we can aggregate
everything at the bottom level you know
it's pretty it's pretty robust
remarkable
danny this is a can i ask you a question
absolutely that was a fantastic graph i
love this
and just in terms of trying to
hypothesize a little bit about why this
might be happening
um do you think this might be partly
driven by
like the
country's specific uh policies and
in helping out with immigration policies
for instance let's say quantum physics
may be
a area of interest right now for the
american government so they make it easy
for the inventor to move
uh at this stage let's say like when
quantum technology is in a more nascent
stage
uh et cetera i'm just giving you like an
example what do you think might be
driving this this is such an
interesting
result
so we're i'm gonna try to to i mean
with this method
um and and i will welcome many ideas
because i'm limited a little bit on the
controls i can put but so then now we're
moving i'm gonna move to some more
tables that i think is getting into that
the very boring answer to your question
from me which is not it's not 100
yet is that you know we do use here
country year fixed effects
technology year fixed effects you're
talking about a country technology year
fixed effect kind of thing
exactly
we do it put here country technology fix
effect and it still holds
um it kills a lot of the variation but
it still holds
um
it certainly can be you know it's
certainly what you're saying it
certainly can be an issue
um
and uh and
yeah so so
that that's why you know if we can
tackle it with better identification it
will it will solve that but it it's it's
a great point and we i don't think we
can go that far
into that um
to claim that that's unexplained by that
but you're absolutely right
then one more question uh so would this
graph look similar if you were looking
at um gmis who like according to this uh
technique of using names um are
immigrants like thinking that maybe
diffusion happens faster if you're
returning to your home country versus if
you're not
um so we
ernest i'm gonna call calling you too we
did we did a lot of this at some point
and i think we didn't really find big
differences
between the two
um
but i might be
i don't know if that means if you want
to jump in or you want to put it in the
chat but if you think i'm wrong but i i
we we didn't find significantly
difference between the two
uh i mean we do find that the effects of
return is i'm gonna find you're a little
bit stronger
um but in terms of the diffusion if
that's what you're referring to
i don't think we found like
significantly different effects
uh but you know we're still we we can i
should we should definitely check out
again i'm calling ernest all the time
even though he's in europe so
um we and he says we did not find
differences in the graph between
immigrants and refugees
and returning sorry
all right um so
so
i mean this is not exactly going to get
to your point but i think
again it's a step on on that direction
so i think that the way we we try to
really tackle this
uh
relationship we're seeing in the graph
in a more rigorous way is is uh is by
changing a little bit the way we're
estimating this
um
and and and basically we're going to
start i'm going to show you a lot of
tables with this regression estimating
this equation here in the middle and
this equation basically it's a little
bit changing the terms i know we're not
supposed to do that in theory so forgive
me but we are like
we're trying um
but basically what we're doing here is
to actually look
now our dependent variable becomes uh
patterns that are in the first tester so
which which you know dummy if if this
pattern that we're looking at is in the
in the among the first ones that we're
looking at
in that technology and country
and to the right uh we have also a gmi i
should have said and i forgot about this
this is really important that the gmi
did i said here
yes do you see here how there's
something that says your previous
previous experience
so so so it's not we're not only
measuring your gmi we're also measuring
uh we're also assigning a one not only
if you're a gmi but also if you patented
in that same technology before you came
okay
so we're a little bit more strict it's
not only about whether you moved but
whether you moved and you already have
experience working in that same
technology
okay
so so that's a kind of an additional
level of um of detail that we're going
here when we're doing these
relationships and i'm sorry i didn't
mention that before
so so we have you know patents on the
first decile
then we have you know our main variable
of interest whether you are a gmi with
previous experience
uh we have some controls at the inventor
level and at the patent level
and then we add a bunch of fixed effects
i mean here i think in the baseline we
only have country year and technology
year
you know in the robustness we have a
bunch with with technology
country
and i have to see aj based on your
question we can go as deep as technology
country here i do i don't know if we
have enough power for that
we also add here in the baseline a fixed
effect for assignments so like you know
if you're patented for ibm we're gonna
have a fixed effect for ibm um just
because you might say well
maybe the person is moving within the
firm or maybe the know-how
belongs to the firm somehow and the
inventor is just executing right so so
that way we're trying to
um uh getting rid of that
um
and actually by the way this should be
assigned a year fixed effect okay so
it's even more more strict
uh and and the controls which i'm not
gonna show you but they have a bunch of
things such as the number of non-patent
literature the number of claims the size
of the team the foreign priority
whether there's a the the size of the
lag between the filing date and the
granting date
a bunch of things okay
um
okay so this is what we found so first
the very simple regression
um
where we find that yes being on the you
know the likelihood of um
the likelihood of being of a pattern
being or
the the
having a gmi explains which much higher
likelihood that your pattern is among
the first ones it's in the first day so
this is what this
estimator is seeing here i'm trying to
the to understand better the the
economic i have to admit i was running
this last night this regression so
i'm still not there yet with economic
significant economic
interpretation
um
it seems to me a little bit small
economically to be honest because if the
likelihood of being in the first vessel
is by definition 10
this is increasing that this by 0.2
percent
by 2.2 percentage points so it's not
huge but i'm still working on this um so
i'm not going to get into that
but we do find that as compared to the
other nine deciles and remember this is
this is a bit of a stricter test because
we're comparing the first xl with other
nine
right
so as compared to the
latest 90 there's a much likely higher
likelihood that if you
um that if you're a gmi you're patenting
in the very first decimal okay and here
we're controlling whether the patent is
a gcp a global collaborative patterns
and and all the fixed effects i told you
before
here we're kind of putting
in the same regression and this refers
to what i was saying before like if
you're a gmi with the previous
experience but also if you're a gmail
without experience so you really you
just move countries but you don't have
you never work on these patterns before
and you know when we put the two of them
together
the explanatory power remains on those
people that actually have the experience
on that same pattern which we think is a
nice quasi-placebo test here
um
then we are kind of dividing whether you
are moving within the same firm or
moving across firms
right
um and here we really don't find there's
there's no big difference
but
deanna a little bit to your question no
not exactly but but here we do find that
when it comes to a returnee
um it's almost twice the magnitude than
when it's just an immigrant
and and i don't know if this is a
special power of returnees or is it that
most returnings are going to develop in
countries where there's more
um
i don't know
there's more room for convergence and
and and
you know more technologies can be um
kind of marriage
um
so so that's kind of our interpretation
okay so this is kind of our main result
you know we're doing a lot of again a
lot of robustness stricter fixed effects
aggregation disaggregation coefficients
seem to be very stable we still find
that that coefficient seems to be very
strong and robust
um
so
what is this okay
so playing i was playing i have to admit
i was playing around yesterday to try to
show you literally moratorium
it's not a very exciting table but i
show it to you anyway um so so basically
what happens you know for different sub
samples if we look at this relationship
with the same specifications so
you know
the first row is is is what i just
showed you with you know this has by the
way i don't know if you notice it's 15
million observations because we are
doing it doing this at the inventor
level
um so this is the same estimator we saw
before
um when we for instance divide between
whether the host countries are
developing or non-ocd
controversies oecd you know we do see a
much
there's many many less
observations in non-oecd countries
because most of the innovation is
happening in the rich nations
um
but regard nevertheless we still find a
much be a bigger um
point estimate
by fifty percent in non-ocd countries
which i think is is consistent with this
idea of returnees
most of them perhaps going to developing
countries when there's more room for
for for
for for innovation and for for new
technologies
we kind of divide this by periods
we didn't find anything there but i'm
not very surprised because these are
very short periods to really study the
phenomenon um people might you know we
might lose a lot of variation of people
moving
between 209 and 2010 right so so there's
there's really i don't think mental
health sense of divide is in periods
um
and and when we do this by types of
technologies you know we do find
i don't think this is terribly
interesting but you know
patents on electricity they seem to to
be there
the 89 observations of of general
tagging seems to seems to have a very
very precise zero
um and and and and patterns of human
necessities which i wrote down what that
means um human necessities are
um where is it
um
agriculture food health clothes personal
items so i think most of the things that
we use in a day today
this thing seems to
you know explain a lot of this diffusion
of know-how
um
so you know we're we're trying to figure
out a better way to release it at the
originality analysis but with this kind
of a direction we're there
and actually since i'm gonna finish
before the end of my time because i just
have one more result
which is on the quality of innovation
right so so
i think an important question that
remains is you know i kind of show you
the stylized facts that gmi's patent
much higher quality innovations and and
quality you know meaning innovations
that that are much more cited
innovations like patents that are more
cited patents that are more original we
have a bunch of metrics i'll show them
to you
to me at least or to us i think
most importantly the question is like
if the knowledge is being imported
uh to to what extent you know that's
reflected in quality right so so kind of
like does the early presence of an
experienced gmi in a country technology
life cycle translates into a higher
quality patterns in the future like is
there a path dependence kind of thing
um like a gmi premium
um
on quality for the rest of the life
cycle of the
of the innovation
and to do this we rely on this the i i
mentioned it very briefly on on some
quality measures um at the patent level
that was put forward by
by a team in the oecd
um and
we're using like these um
measures like forward citations which is
the typical the most common measure for
innovation something called breakthrough
generality originality radicalness and
an index that takes all of them together
um i'm you know i can go through all of
them if you have a question but i you
know i have them all the time
but these are you know just different
measures of quality of a patent how
important they are how innovative they
are in their technologies
how much do they rely on other
technologies how much
do they open the door for other
technologies all these kind of things
um and basically the question we're
trying to answer the best way we found
and trying to answer and here's also
some some uh
maybe there's a better way and i'd love
to hear about that
is basically what is essentially what is
the average quality per decile
um if in the first decile there was a
higher presence of gmis okay so it's
basically kind of interacting
each test style with
the the share of gmis in the first
decimal
i'm just gonna i'm not gonna show you
taylor's gonna show you a graph
and the answer is that we don't find
anything um
i think uh
you know
you you would start to be suspicious if
i show you have results for everything
so i'm showing you something i don't
have results for
um
so so so here basically
you know this is the average quality in
each textile in the left graph and this
is the the gma you know
if there was a gmi in the first few
patents what is the average quality
where's the gmi premium
and even though
the coefficients are higher you know
they're not precise enough to be able to
say something so so there's really no
difference
um
in quality this is just with one measure
of quality which is this index that has
all of them but you know it doesn't
matter which quality measure we use
we don't really see
um a lot of differences so you know
that's that's um
um you know we can't conclude anything
very special about gmi's
playing a big role in the initial stages
and also
playing a big role in the quality of the
of the innovation in the future
we just don't see any difference
um needless to say you know this is also
done with all the fixed effects and all
the controls et cetera et cetera
um so let me let me actually
uh
start to wrap up um but and and then
maybe we can have some time for
questions i would love to hear your
suggestions uh because we need a lot of
them
um
so basically what what what you know
we're trying to do here is to
contribute by by continuing to uncover a
phenomenon of of um
of growing importance in the
globalization of of knowledge of the
production of knowledge which is these
global mobile inventors that um we
believe is an under research phenomenon
and
we find that they have a creek they play
a critical role both immigrants and
attorneys in the diffusion of knowledge
as
as we measure it which is through the
emergence of new technologies
uh but they don't seem to define some
sort of quality path dependence
um and in terms of next steps you know
we we do see we know that we have
challenges with identification some of
you you raised here and and i totally
agree
so we we do we did try some ideas and
try to to kind of instrument perhaps for
the movements and so on they weren't
very
terribly successful
um
[Music]
you know we we
we're looking also into other methods
maybe looking something into an order
probably not to be so harsh between
comparing the first tesla to the other
90 percent
um and being more precise on that and
some things that we're looking in the
future some of them we started looking
already to think about recombination of
technologies whether immigrant whether
gmis are
playing a role in countries uh combining
technologies
not just by looking at the first at you
know the main technology code of the
patent but all the different technology
codes that a patent could have
um
looking into whether
you know this diffusion process um
changes whether you're
the first few patents are mixed teams or
not i mean is the gmi working on on on
his or her own or is it gmi working with
local inventors those that play a role
in the diffusion
um we certainly need to play more a
little heterogeneity and the sizes of
firms and and and also some more
inventors organized in terms of
demographics
so anyway um i'm gonna stop here um i
thank you very much i know again this is
i mean i don't want to say it's a purely
descriptive paper but i know that we
have some challenges and identification
um but i we still think we're adding a
lot of value just by really describing
this phenomenon and getting as deep as
we can but i will welcome
more of your ex so far excellent
comments
um and thank you for being here thanks
for
danny listening question very
interesting by the way um
i remember seeing um
at the bernstein paper some impact on
on
of the immigrants on citations and the
market value patterns top patterns and i
i was a little bit uh
puzzled when you show the
no impact on the patent outcomes and i
was thinking if
it may be something on selection maybe
once
of the migrant versus the gms or i don't
know i wanted to get you ideas on what
you think could be explaining the
difference no impact on the quality
measures you mean
yeah on the citations on the forward
citations or on
i mean
we do see that gmis
on their um you know on their own
they they their patterns are of much
higher quality
that we see
we're trying here to get to something
that it's i don't know if it's a stretch
but it was like
you know are they
setting up like higher quality for the
rest of the people who are patenting
that content technology
uh and that's where we don't find
anything right so so like if you
remember the example i gave at the
beginning of this chilean scientist
ismail meno who came and did one patent
and then i
i said that there were 19 other patents
that happened after him
you know we don't find in these 19 other
patents where
of much higher quality than they would
have been you know if you believe you
know
being a little bit exaggerating with
identification if they would have been
if there if israel is my men wouldn't
have been there that's what we're
getting at
so it's not inconsistent with the fact
that immigrants pattern higher quality
or gmis
we're trying to get a little bit
beyond that and see if there's a path
dependence of quality for the rest of
the life cycle
yeah from the diffusion component now
yeah i was just thinking that the
immigrants that were coming permanently
are more likely to have that effect
right as opposed to the ones that are
might be returned but
right so here we're pulling everybody
together not only for
patents by immigrants for patents by
everybody
um
so we could do that we could try to
define
you know we yeah that's
we could look into that
thank you
yes
hi uh
i'm very vocal today but sorry
um so one question i had was that so
what what you're trying to explain is
that there's the existence of the gmi
influence the quality of
patterns in the subsequent periods
um another way of looking at the
question maybe in which you may have
already looked at it whether is that
maybe the same quality if patent was
going to arrive but maybe the time it
took to get there may be shortened
did i clarify myself
so it's a question of not a matter of
whether it was going to emerge
the same quality would have emerged
uh or not it's that would have
would would it have merged in the same
pace
in the absence of a gmi
yeah i know that's possible yes that
we're seeing i mean yeah it's possible
that the quality
you're talking about the quality in
particular right quality in particular
so the question would have been
if the same quality pattern was going to
emerge regardless of the
existence of the gmi would have still
would it have emerged faster
because i think the question you're
asking is actually a stronger question
it's a harder thing to happen
there must be in the way i'm not very
familiar with this literature but it's
almost assuming that there is something
something inherently different about the
gmi
that would have that would be linked to
the emergence of the idea
which may be the case i don't know
but to me it sounds like the question
that asking it differently about the
timing is a
slightly more lenient way that could
help you generate further
ideas
okay i might follow up on line with you
on that um because
i want to make sure i got it but i think
that's a great point
that's okay with you
thank you of course
i think lucian has a
question
oh yes uh thank you great presentation
so i don't know if i missed something
but are you able to observe the gender
of the
inventor
uh i don't know would be interesting to
look at how the point estimate or may
change depending on the sets of inventor
so i don't know yeah well that's kind of
a little bit what i meant here at the
very last line so like
that i went very fast so you didn't miss
it like you know we might want to look a
little bit more into demographics so i
don't think we have we don't have the
gender but but maybe with the algorithms
and the names
we can do something to to
to infer
gender okay
and we definitely would would that's
something i'm definitely interested in
okay thank you
um i think jeremy has a question
yeah um thanks i think this this topic
is really interesting i'm wondering if
you know as you work on this more you
can say more push forward on what drives
the emergence of gmis in the first place
so i'm wondering
you know are our gmis this is this is
related to heterogeneity by you know the
characteristics of the country of origin
but our gmi's more likely to come from
countries that are more say advanced in
the industry where they are then
patenting in
and if so you know why are they
migrating to patent i think these sorts
of questions are interesting i'm
wondering if you have any thoughts about
that
yeah i mean that's super interesting we
we have some thoughts
but more like from the identification
part right like trying to see if there's
something that could explain these
movements um
you know in ways that it's not related
to anything else so that we can exploit
a little bit of that
um but i don't think we have
i mean i think
it's a good question i think everything
there's a lot of information we could do
to get there it's all going to be
very endogenous right
um as we have it but but it's it's yeah
it's certainly a good direction to go i
took thank you
yeah thanks
um
yeah
i don't know i don't know if there's any
more questions i i want to be respectful
of everybody's time
so i like i will again come back to my
earlier question like do you have some
sense about like you know what are the
push or pull factors uh when it comes to
gmi's
like are they being attracted or are
they being pushed out maybe financial
crisis or recession during period in
latin american countries and all are
playing a big role in pushing uh people
out of the country like do you have some
intuition about that yeah
i mean
i just um
and this is kind of the universe of
inventors right so so to some extent so
there's certainly there has to be so we
haven't explored this very much so there
has to be some cases in which we can
explore some push and pull factors it's
probably not going to apply to the whole
sample
um
and that's something we could certainly
look at to see if there's
i think the main challenge there is that
because most of the inventors are are
actually located in you know the few
rich countries
um
which
you know
there's not gonna be a lot of variation
of like
political
i mean who knows i mean after what
happened the past four years who knows
but
there's not gonna be a lot of variation
i guess on
if you're thinking about identification
which is what i'm thinking
um because most of them are either going
or coming from
the rich countries
yeah so that i was i was thinking like
maybe like you know segmenting your data
along
similar countries like in a movement
among similar countries versus con like
you know countries are very dissimilar
so on economic uh criterion like you
know maybe movement from oecd countries
to america versus to countries like
india which is quite poor
and how does that impact the quality of
patents
it will be very
nice to you
yeah we can look into i mean the closest
to that is kind of a table i show you
very fast where we're seeing like the
effect on not when when on we will only
look at non-oecd countries that was like
um
the magnitudes were higher
um but you know yeah there's so much we
can do with this in advance
i agree i mean these are all
super great comments i so much
appreciate all of them really yeah thank
you thank you that's a very interesting
word thank you thank you
next time i'll come in person
[Laughter]
thank you very much and
i think um
for other questions so if you can
contact danny we can circulate the email
and so for everyone thank you very much
uh
danny for everyone bye everyone thank
you bye